[Musique]
mon ancêtre Péro vivait au Mexique au
bons des chercheurs de pépit le braveom
cherchait des musi pour charmer sait il
est vrai que trou l' bouillante ail la J
herbante le bon Dieu les étoiles
filantes mon encêtre inventa la Bamba il
se disait caramba tout fais les
sa le vol et
la alors pour que le SL des P était dans
un état mon ancêtre c'est vraient La
Bamba
j'étaiso j'ai jouc au mais j'étais si
mignon qu'il s'écri mados nous
l'appellerons Bamba
mon ancêtre Pedro est mort sans tenaire
en laissant ses moustaches à mon père sa
guitare et ses cordes à ma mère et
toutes ces pépist pép quand j'ai eu 21
ans quand j'ai lu son testament j'ai
trouvé tu sais qui j'ai trouvé tu sais
quoi non pas le j'ai trouvé La Bamba
elle est passé parci elle passe par là
elle est dans par par celui qui voudra
j'ai F au poab à la le passe partout
Bamba car mon ancêtre Pedro m'a donné sa
danse com on fait un cadeau à l'enfance
com on lance matin la cadence d'un refin
qui n'en finira
[Musique]
pas à mon tour à présent moi je vous la
donne La Bamba n'appartient à personne
elle est faite pour qui donne c'est la
fête en en voilà de Panama Panama des
savanes à la paampa chacun dans La
Bamba les parents les bambin m les
actorin ne sont plus pour le twist ils
le trouvent trop triste ne sont plus
pour le rock il le trouvent trop to ils
le trouvent trop to quand ils vont dans
les night club quand ils branchent leur
pic au première communion à la fin des
banqu il chant t bamb
moncêre Pédro sur son grand nuage doit
bicher envoyant les visages des milliers
d'enfants de tous les âges qui lui dans
sa présence à pendant que ça pépit il
prépar des petits plat il voit partout
partout des vivants d'aujourd'hui qui se
fait un bon coup de bambentr elle est
passé par elle passe par là elle est par
par celui qui voudra de l'AB à la et
pass partout en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Bacal